[оплески]
дуже
[музика]
вбити
люди повинні зустрічати російський світ з
квітами як мінімум а якщо ні хай
пізнає велич нашої армії справа в тому
що вони вже пізнали велич
обійдемося переговорами вай вай вай фай і
на кубі з кульбі сина та путіна доступу
і на дупу і neko машка
та раковині під кубі на кубі з кулька
сіна і як глибина
сочі на
фурманів думав для не раз без мародерів
пластину досі скупість бронників диму
немає м'яча стратив подвійних пластина бляти
цікавих перевіркою на інший бік
від нихуя не бронник [ __ ]
міста карбування крок
йдуть військовослужбовці
повітрянодесантних військ парадний розрахунок
рязанської вищої
повітряно-десантного
[музика]
сьогодні ми тобі літа малюємо син по і
велику тишу ставу не прикидайся
мертвим потрібно негайно припинити цю
атаку че [ __ ] де мені знайти команді на
руси і а він там солоденькому будиночки де
[ __ ] укриття зроблено з піщаних мішків
з цукром тільки не переплутай там є
ще укриття списаних килимів y'all
історія з бронників не закінчилася і
sowerby насадка пікселів їхній підорської
бляти ось у це та його
ось так завойовники завойовують
[музика]
а
і
[музика]
їх
[оплески]
[музика]
тіла мама бджола царків валіза аветис у
сакан апа стисненого дядька смарті налетять
кроку дивую зі а я шоу сильним а інші
дядько та піна густа deaton та дядько а за
країна сатана one
[музика]
не новий господарському
desired малайка пісковим
[музика]
ми
[оплески]
взагалі [ __ ] я вб'ю дак вб'ю
[музика]
букіна acne борис гулько сіна та
[оплески]
[музика]
букіна акорду ризикуючи сіна та посудина
доступ
і на дупу і ногам ваш катарі
і на кевіна і від вуді на курей борис
гулко сіна та
кудіна доступ навіщо
я живу та ніг ваш canary
це кевін ногах
[музика]
крайня плоть піднімається над головкою
ось так затискається, щоб не травмувати
головку давайте gear мишей
цей божественний, а я зараз вам покажу
звідки на Білорусь готувалася напад
командир це наказ особисто від шойгу потрібно
відступати командир може бути з'їдемося
ми й так уже обосрались із цим гостомель
їм [ __ ] [ __ ] тут ще 300 доларів
хабар ми друга армія світу ми
укомплектовані за останнім словом
техніки
тільки подивися на наші сучасні
каски і це вони ще не бачили нашої
кавалерії
[музика]
а
вийти дуже його я стріляю
навколо
нього там літає байрактор
в Україні в цьому
[музика]
цілком упевнений вони розуміли його туди
джиночка підходи та
колодязі ходимо я для вас
купуєте в кожній
віджала
цинк з патронами про
тесла у нас 25 і воку
25 і воді слава нації, і нехай ці люди
слава україні слава нації та пізнати
російської федерації та поліцейський
Детальніше
за українець